[Music]
[Applause]
exiled Queens fight for their family's
survival Dicky lady readies her Cubs for
battle as one Prince begins her
training another has the throne firmly
in her
sight the young hold the key to
power The Savage kingdom is yours for
the
taking
[Music]
trapped by the
flood deol lady is forced to raise her
three Cubs in a war
zone
the waters Retreat means Escape might
soon be
possible but this harrowing Journey will
demand the Cubs pull their
[Music]
weight
time for a
test remember all you've been
taught
SEO is a l
leader but this is one tough
[Music]
piglet dick lady is not
impressed this this is not a
[Music]
game don't let him get
away
that's
enough stand
[Music]
aside
it won't even feed
four it's a waste of
time the lady's Cubs are far from
ready he in a kingdom ruled by
tyrants there are no Second
Chances Commander mammutti rules the
heartlands with an iron
grip with numbers on her
side she and her rotten Army
run
rampant now mut's only
concern is her own
legacy her son will never be more than a
foot
soldier her Clan's future
rests with her
daughter one day LED he will be
Commander but the entitled princess
better step
up or all of mutti's efforts will be in
vain sear also has her eye on the
kingdom she's determined to rise to
power she and the Matata Pride are
growing their own
Army but Sons outnumber
daughters all males eventually
leave
only daughters stay and
fight they are the Warriors she
needs sear is playing the long
game her chance to take the throne will
come across the kingdom new lives
[Music]
flourish but even they are shown no
mercy
[Music]
Pula maintains her High standing in the
forest to keep it she seizes every
opportunity
[Music]
for
some life is brutally
short
Pula has no time for
sentiment One Life feeds
another
midi could one day inherit this
Bountiful
Forest but Pula is growing
old and it takes time to raise a perfect
assassin news of death travels
fast
the Matata pride is in for the
feast why pass up an easy
meal
Pula must protect
maidi right into the trees
[Music]
now
a leopard killed one of Sear's
Cubs she will seize any chance to take
revenge
[Music]
Pula knows the Matata Pride could end
her
Legacy don't move a
muscle don't even
breathe
she evades the
Lions for now
but it's a terrifying reminder just how
vulnerable midi
is enjoy these moments of peace my
little
[Music]
one your real training will soon
begin
mot's hirs join the marauding
hord this is ledi's first time at the
front
everyone in this Army is out for
themselves the princess is
nervous and she's not big enough to
fight
yet
mutzi is not known for
patience or
compassion her daughter will one day
rule LTI must stand up and take what's
rightfully
[Music]
hers
exiled to the edge of the
flood rohara and the Western Pride are
[Music]
desperate they haven't killed in
days
[Music]
their cubs are
impatient
hungry it will be a while before they
catch their own
dinner until then their providers must
provide
[Music]
one lioness boldly does her
Duty
but she finds herself in a dangerous
neighborhood
[Music]
this is Matata Pride
territory the Western Pride female will
never be welcome at their
table but desperation drives her
forward
she's come too
far and is
spotted sear does not tolerate uninvited
[Music]
guests the penalty Will Be
Blood
territory is
everything and sear will defend what she
has left to the
death
sear is protecting more than just a
[Music]
meal
hidden away even from her own
[Music]
sisters two
newborns two future soldiers to add to
her
Army
she will dutifully feed and nurture
[Music]
them but they are both just
Sons useless for her long-term
[Music]
plans
Sear's dreams of Power are on hold for
now an Assassin's blood runs deep
mat CII just needs to harness
[Music]
it Pula is a wise and experienced
teacher but has to work
[Music]
hard months of play will hone mid's
skills
[Music]
their every move is being
watched
Ma's father blue eyes is
[Music]
back with her Legacy at stake Pula knows
he cannot be
trusted
he has a taste for young
blood and a leopard never changes Its
Spots blue eyes won't think twice about
killing his own
daughter but right
now he lusts
for
[Music]
Pula she must keep blue eyes away from
her
daughter maidi is oblivious to the
danger pula's young assassin is not yet
ready for the the real
[Music]
world the shifting Seasons Drive a
fortune right towards the Western
Pride the flood brings with it
unexpected
gifts but these beasts are far from Easy
pickings water makes hunting
difficult but one break Queen won't let
this opportunity
pass beaten to the punch she's out of
her
depth
w
[Applause]
no gripon power is
forever
but the others will not take the
risk the queen is still determined to
make a
kill one of these could keep us going
for
days
[Music]
the reward will be worth
it
[Music]
without backup she never stood a
chance
[Music]
dick lady is used to offending for
herself
[Music]
but with three Cubs life's
Relentless let's do this
together
diil will
lead no
[Music]
mistakes
SEO targets a young
victim his instincts are
flawless but he needs help to bring it
down
help your
[Applause]
brother their own kill a
last finally the Cubs prove their
worth but are they ready for the
challenges that lie
ahead
Pula is an elite
Hunter but Mar's hunger is
insatiable
her constant demands are taking their
[Music]
toll with thieves
everywhere a prize like this must be
kept out of
reach at each step is getting harder
maii isn't used to waiting her
turn but she must be
taught
her first taste of tough
love Pula doesn't have the resolve to
see it
through after all m cidi is the
future she is all that matters
now
weak and
exhausted pula's time is running
up her cup must become
independent and fast or she'll never
survive maidi is still so
naive she'd be lost without her
mother she needs more time to learn the
dangers of the
realm before she can face The Savage
King kingom
[Music]
alone the Western pride is struggling to
make ends
me the marsh is drying
up and the buffalo are
gone always
hungry tempers
flare the last thing they need is
competition
the cheaters are in the wrong
place at the wrong
[Music]
time if they're caught in Western Pride
territory
they will be
[Music]
killed
SEO takes a wrong turn and is singled
out his mother can't help him
now
you can
run but you can't
hide I'll be
[Music]
waiting
di a lady and two Cubs make it to
safety but without
SEO her calls go
unanswered staying is a risk to all
their
lives P lady won't leave without her
son SEO is all alone on the other side
of the western
Pride the night is dark and full of
Terrors
[Music]
stranded in the darkness surrounded by
lions sepo hears his mother's
calls but if he blows his cover the
pride will
attack
Dawn brings
death and a gift for princess
ledi
she will stake her claim to this
kill flexing her royal
[Music]
muscles even if they are just dirty
birds this feels
good everyone will fear me when I'm in
charge
SEO survives the
[Applause]
night but a wall of lions still stands
between him and his
family
now he must run the
gauntlet any mistakes this time will
mean certain
death
his speed is all he
has
but speed is all he
needs SEO escapes with his
life but his mother is nowhere to be
[Music]
seen
Jal lady was right not to leave without
[Music]
him
on the edge of this terrible
Kingdom the family is
[Music]
reunited dick lady has looked death in
the face too many
times but finally her Cubs have come of
[Music]
age now her young family can make their
escape
[Music]
Victorious
survivors of the Savage
[Music]
Kingdom